( music)
- All right, thank you.
Thanks, Timberley, for the invitation.
In fact when she originally
invited me to submit a proposal
I was thinking, "Well, I
don't know what I do in Canvas
"that is special or is different
from what other people do."
I've never seen the competition.
I certainly never use quizzes,
or some of these embedding
of multimedia material on Canvas.
So I really thought hard
about what essentially sums up
the way that I've been using Canvas,
and I think it boils down to the way
that I've used the home
page as the go-to resource
for a lot of things we do in class.
So just to give you a bit of background,
the class I'm showing right here
is a pretty large statistics class.
There's about a hundred students,
and we don't have regular
quizzes and tests,
we do have two exams
throughout the semester,
but we do have regular reading assignments
and homework assignments and so on.
So, one of the questions
that I'm sure you all have
from students is, "What's the homework?"
Or "What's the reading assignment?
"Where can I find this
that we did in class?"
And for me, the easiest
way to just put everything
in a central place has been
to make use of the home page.
This is just one of the
pages that I've created,
and I clicked to set it as
the home page, and I design it
to be sort of a growing
syllabus, if you will.
So initially it'll be week one of class,
and you probably won't
see very much beyond,
say, up to this point.
So there will be essential information,
like who are the TAs in the course,
who are the ULAs, we use
ULAs in this course as well,
when are their office hours,
and all this is dynamic
in the sense that we can
change it at any time.
It's a website that we can
go in, modify as needed,
in order to get the most
up-to-date information.
So the way that things
progressed is, obviously,
the important things are way at the top,
and then I like to organize my material
on a week to week basis,
so I try to have a top
level heading per week.
That's just week one, the date,
what did we cover in class,
what are the slides that go
along with the material in class
and what are some computer code examples
that would come along with that.
And I think that this gives
me just a very nice way
of pointing students to the page.
I can even say things like,
"If you happen to miss class,
"feel free to just keep
up to date by looking at
"what's going on on the home page.
"Everything is posted there,
you wouldn't miss anything."
The only thing that's
missing is maybe videos
of our in-class lectures,
but I'm very resistant
against that kind of thing.
Other things that I
would want to highlight,
is I did try doing something like this
with the modules section of Canvas,
and I heard a lot of you use
Canvas very successfully.
So I do have a slide
example from an earlier,
a different course where
I did try to implement
the same kind of thing using modules.
And I thought this would
make my life easier
because I could just go ahead and create
these high level folders
from week to week,
I can include assignments, I
can include any other files
that I'd like to include normally.
But what I found is that this
is a little less flexible.
It's much harder for me to
format the names of things
to include bold facing for
things I'd like to highlight,
and it takes up a lot of space.
So week one, for this class for example,
stretches a full page basically.
I have to scroll down to get to week two.
Whereas I tend now to prefer
just having everything
on this home page where
I can even have things
that are just text, right?
So things like when office hours are,
links to practice exams,
solutions to practice exams.
Having it all be in that one central place
seems to me the easiest way to go.
I guess I still have time remaining.
So since this is not a
Canvas propaganda session,
I think I want to also
talk a little bit about
the struggles that I've had with Canvas,
if I may, since I have an audience.
So in my class we have about
four people, five people
grading for every single assignment,
and we do make use of
Canvas’ grading tool.
I really do like the speed grader,
that everybody can go in
and see the PDF submissions,
they can annotate the PDFs,
work with the rubrics,
and this makes it really easy
if you don't want people to
be swapping back and forth
paper assignments, for example.
One challenge that I've
had, however, is that
if you have multiple people
grading simultaneously,
the rubric, be very careful,
because they will sometimes
overwrite each other's
points, and I've had that
when two graders were
grading simultaneously.
Someone may be grading problem one,
someone grading problem five,
and maybe they're just offset
by a couple of students,
and somebody will click on
submit and save, and boom,
the other grade completely
disappears into thin air.
So I'm hoping that someday
we're able to resolve this.
I see this as sort of the main complaint
that I have with Canvas in the meantime.
But otherwise, I think
the students have been
fairly satisfied with being able to have
everything in one place.
Sorry about that.
And being able to see their
grades, see their feedback,
and being able to submit
things very easily
without having to appear in
person to turn things in.
That's all I have.
(audience applauds)
- [Audience Member] So,
the grading challenge,
I don't know if I understood you clearly.
So presume two teaching fellows
are grading simultaneously
the same assignment.
- Exactly.
- [Audience Member] They
would be doing it why?
Is it accidental, or
you deliberately assign,
like, the TF one will
grade problems one to two,
and TF two will grade
problems three to four.
I mean, why would that problem occur?
- That's a very good question.
So, in my mind, because we want
to have our ULAs and
TAs grade consistently,
we want to, instead of having
them grade different students,
maybe they just grade different problems.
That way everybody, one TF
will grade all of problem one,
one TF will grade all of problem two,
and so in that case it is
possible for two of them
to be grading the same
person simultaneously.
- [Audience Member] Can you
set it so that the students
receive an email announcement
when you update the home page?
- I have not figured out how to do that.
That would certainly be ideal, yeah.
- [Audience Member] I think
there might be a notify users
that an update has been made,
at the bottom of the page
before you hit submit.
- Ah. I should look into
that, I think that would be
an excellent sort of improvement
upon the current system
to have students see that
new material has been posted.
- [Audience Member] I
don't think that happens
on pages, unfortunately.
It is assignments, you
can do it for assignments
but not on pages right now.
- Okay. Someday.
(laughter)
Thank you very much.
- [Audience Member] Thank you.
(applause)
(gentle xylophone music)